alors donc là la partie grill on fait
répression des fraudes et services
vétérinaires ensemble pour un contrôle
sanitaire ce matin dans les cuisines du
camping de rier comme chaque été ses
inspections se multiplient tout comme
ses opérations conjointes à différents
services de l'État ce matin donc à
chacun son rôle vérifier l'étiquetage
essentiellement pour Madame et pour
Monsieur le rangement des produits la
température et bien sûr les date de
péremption petite
erreur
à consommer jusqu'au 6 août 2008 une
erreur sans conséquence qui vaudra au
directeur du site une simple
notification car malgré cela le bilan
dans cette cuisine reste positif c'est
un établissement de restauration on va
dire de petite capacité qui présente
aucun aucune nonconformité majeure au
niveau de l'agencement des locaux au
niveau de des équipements au niveau de
de l'hygiène donc qui paraît tout à fait
satisfaisant pour Madame oui oui tout à
fait entièrement d'accord avec mon
collègue c'est c'est un l'aménagement
tout est propre il y a pas de souci on
appréende toujours un petit peu mais on
le prend plus dans le sens à faire
évoluer notre technique plus dans le
sens à B toutes les normes on les
connaît pas toujours parfaitement donc
au contraire quand des services comme ça
spécialisés viennent on
préfère s'y intéresser et finalement
apprendre des choses côté de la piscine
du camping deux autres services sont en
action ici la DAS pour l'inspection de
l'eau qui ne voit aucune recommandation
à faire mais également la Direction de
la Jeunesse et des Sports qui là juge
plutôt de la sécurisation du site
exemple alors l'affichage des
profondeurs c'est un élément obligatoire
un baigneur doit savoir s'il va aller
dans 80 cm d'eau ou dans 2 m là j'ai a
priori pas vu de panneaux he qui doiv
être posé fixé de façon définitive et
permanente sur le bord du bassin ces
opérations conjointes reste cependant
difficile à organiser la plupart du
temps ces services agissent seul ou à
deux et ne font souvent que de simples
recommandations ils ont donc un rôle de
conseil auprès de professionnels du
tourisme qui ne peuvent pas toujours
connaître l'ensemble de la législation
mais ces contrôles peuvent aussi se
conclure par des avertissements des
mises en demeure voire des fermetures
d'établissement lorsque la sécurité des
clients est mise en péril sur les 180
contrôles que les services vétérinaires
ont effectué depuis le début du mois de
juillet ont été prononcé 15 appppel à
l'ordre quatre mises en demeure et trois
fermetures d'établissement